ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะเดือนอะไร
คะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะตีพ.ต.ต.
ปีคศอะไรคะมีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
re4 พ.ศ
ต.ค.ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
นี่นี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 17 เดือนเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศเต๊ตปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
วันนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 19:00
น
19:00 นกี่นาที
7:50 นค่ะภาษิตลาทีนี้ก็เป็น
ในเวลากลางคืนนะคะไม่ใช่เวลากลางวัน
เวลากลางคืนแล้วครูฟ้า 1 ทุ่มแล้วหิวไหม
คะหิวกะท้องเนี่ยโอ๊ยส้มตำต้มยำผัด
กระเพราก๋วยเตี๋ยวสปาเก็ตตี้ KFC หิวหิว
ค่ะดูปากรูฟ้าเนี่ย
หิวเอาครูฟ้า
หมูอันนี้บ้านครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะบ้านครูฟ้า
แล้วก็
เซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่น by ครูฟ้ากับเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
เนี่ย
อยู่ใกล้ไหมใกล้ไหมหรือว่าอยู่ใกล้มากๆ
อยู่
ใกล้ค่ะอยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้
ขอเชิญเดินไปได้ใช่เดินไปได้แต่เหนื่อย
หน่อยแต่อยู่ใกล้งั้นเดินไปได้หรอไม่ไกล
ไม่ไกลดีค่ะถ้าครูฟ้าหิวก็เดินไปเซเว่น
ได้เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นอยู่ใกล้ๆไกลฮะค่ะ
เขียนเค้าปิดเราอันนี้เลยอะไรอ่ะเราก็จะ
มาคุยเกี่ยวกับใกล้ไกลไกลๆใกล้ใกล้ไกล
ใกล้ๆไกลๆไกลๆใกล้ๆนักเรียนแบบ
ง่ายๆนักเรียน So  Easy นะใกล้ไกลๆไก่
หรอใกล้ใหญ่ฟ้าใช่ไหม
บ้านครูป๊ากับเซเว่นแหละอยู่ใกล้นะอยู่
ใกล้แต่บ้าน
ถ้าผู้หญิงไม่ใช่บ้านนอก Condominium
คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงกับ
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นอยู่ใกล้ๆ
ได้กับอะไรคะให้มากๆไง
คอนโดมีเลี้ยงผู้หญิงเซเว่นอยู่ใกล้ๆได้
แค่ไหนคุณผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเดินเดินประมาณ
1 นาที
หนึ่งนาทีเดินเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นไม่เหลือ
ใหญ่เนี่ยใกล้ๆ
โอ้โหใกล้มากเลยผู้หญิงดีค่ะเวลาของผู้
หญิงอยู่ไหนผู้หญิงก็จะเดินไปเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นใกล้ๆ
ทรายได้น้องก็วันเนี้ยเราก็จะมาดูว่าบ้าน
ครูฟ้าอยู่ใกล้หรืออยู่ไกลกับอะไรบ้าง
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงจะมีมีรูปของ
สถานที่นะคะได้ค่ะอ่ะโอเคอ่าเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นไปแล้วเนาะบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่ใกล้
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นนะคะอ่ะ
มาดูอันนี้ดีกว่าค่ะครูฟ้ารู้ไหมในรูป
เนี่ยที่ไหน
ตลาดใช่ไหมคะตลาดเนี่ย
บ้านอันนี้บ้านครูฟ้าแล้วก็
ตลาดนะตลาด
GA ใช่ไหมคะหรือว่าบ้านครูฟ้าแล้วก็ตลาด
นัดบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่
AU ไกลตลาดหรือว่าบ้านครูฟ้าบีบีอยู่
ใกล้ตลาดคะบ้านครูฟ้าบ้า
e  mail ฟ้านะคะ
อยู่
ใกล้ตลาดค่ะแต่ว่าอยู่ไกลกว่าเซเว่นอ๋อ
อ๋อบ้านครูฟ้าก็คืออันนี้บ้านครูฟ้า
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
ตลาด
ไหว้ครูบาอยู่กระใกล้ตลาดแต่อยู่ไกลกว่า
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นให้หาอยู่ไกลกว่าเป็น
เอเว่นหน้าแต่ก็อะไรตลาดเดินไปได้ไหม
เดินได้แต่เหนื่อย
อ่อนขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ไหมขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
โอเคค่ะขี่เหมยใส่ได้ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ใช้เวลาประมาณ
1 นาที
ให้จริงๆ 1 นาทีโอ้โหใกล้หรอบ้านครูฟ้า
อยู่ใกล้ตลาดริดีนะคะไปซื้อเราก็ทำอาหาร
ได้
ค่ะแล้วคอนโดคุณครูหญิงล่ะคะอยู่ใกล้หรือ
ว่าไกลตลาด
อยู่ใกล้ตลาดค่ะอยู่ใกล้
ใกล้ตลาดนะใจคิดว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์นะคะขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ประมาณ
3 นาที
3  3 นาที
มอเตอร์ไซค์นะ 3 นาทีนะอยู่ใกล้ค่ะบ้าน
ครูหญิงอยู่ใกล้ตลาดบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่ใกล้
ตลาดเนาะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะที่ต่อไปผู้ที่อนิด
อะไรนะคะสถานที่ในรูป
อะไร
วัดค่ะชื่อวัดวัดนะคะบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่ใกล้
หรืออยู่ไกลวัด
บ้านครูฟ้า
อยู่ใกล้ๆไหมไก่ค่ะมาอยู่ไกลวัดเหรออยู่
ไกลวัดหาครูหญิงเดินไปไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ต้องขับรถไป
ขับรถกี่นาทีจากบ้านครูฟ้าในบ้านถ้าไกล
เนี่ยบ้านครูฟ้าก็จะเล็กๆใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็
ไป
วัดเนี่ยขับรถกี่นาที
ขับรถประมาณ
[เพลง]
30 นาทีค่ะ
30 นาที
โอเคไกลนะไกล i5
คืออะไรคือแล้วครูหญิงราคะคอนโดมิเนียม
ครูหญิงกับวัด
Condominium ผู้หญิงแดกไกลหรือใกล้วัด
ใกล้ค่ะใกล้หรอเดินได้เดินได้ครูฟ้าอ่ะ
ครูหญิงเดินน่าจะประมาณ 15 นาทีก็ถือว่า
ใกล้นะใกล้นะเดินถ้ามอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ย 1 นาที
[เพลง]
ใกล้มาหารอยู่ใกล้วัดค่ะจะไม่สวยแบบนี้นะ
ไม่ใช่วัดนี้นะคะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะอุ้ยอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้าในรูปนี้สถานที่ต้องเรียนค่ะโรง
เรียนหรอบ้านครูป๋าอยู่ใกล้หรือว่าอยู่
ไกลโรงเรียน
บ้านครูฟ้าอยู่
ไกลโรงโรงเรียนค่ะอยู่ไกลโรงเรียน
ไกลมากไกลมากถูกขับรถกี่นาทีไกลมากขับรถ
ประมาณ 40 นาที
34  said ขับรถหรือขึ้นขับรถนะคะขับรถ
เนาะเดินไม่ได้นะคะไม่ได้เราอยู่ไกลโรง
เรียน
ไกลค่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะบ้านอยู่ใกล้หรือ
ไกลโรงเรียน
ไกลค่ะไกลเพราะครูหญิงเนี่ยมองใช่มั้ยจาก
บ้านแล้วก็มองไม่เห็นโรงเรียนเลยนะคิดว่า
ไกลไกลโรงเรียน
อะไรมากใส่ค่ะต่อไปค่ะสถานที่ต่อไปอะไร
ที่ไหนคะในรูปธนาคาร
ไปธนาคารน้องธนาคารในรูปเนี่ยสีเขียว
เนี่ยนะคะธนาคารอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ธนาคารกสิกรค่ะอ่ะธนาคารอะไรก็ได้นะ
ธนาคารอะไรก็ได้นะบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่
ใกล้หรือว่าอยู่ไกลธนาคารคะ
บ้านครูฟ้าอยู่ใกล้ธนาคารค่ะให้มากเหรอ
ครูฟ้าในอ่ะใกล้อ่ะเดินประมาณ 2 นาที
ไอ้เดินนะเดินเดิน 2 นาที
ใกล้เนาะอยู่ใกล้ธนาคาร
คือคอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงราคาอยู่ใกล้หรือ
ไกลธนาคาร
ใกล้ธนาคารค่ะเงินเดินได้ไหมเดินเหมือน
ครูฟ้าเลยสองนาที
ใกล้นี่เม็ด
การเลี้ยงผู้หญิงนะนี่เป็นถนนนะคะถนนอัน
นี้ธนาคาร
อันนี้นะคะธนาคารให้ไม่เดินเดินๆถึงแล้ว
ใกล้มากๆนะคะเหมือนครูฟ้าอ่ะต่อไปค่ะสถาน
ที่ต่อไป
อะไรหักหรือหญิงครูฟ้าเห็นแล้วรู้ไหมที่
นี่ที่ไหน
Cafe
คาเฟ่หรือว่าร้านกาแฟสมัยร้านกาแฟเราไป
ดื่มอเมริกาโนเอสเปรสโซ่ลาเต้นะคะครูฟ้า
ขา Cafe แล้วกันเนาะเพราะว่าคาเฟ่เนี่ย
มันทำงานได้ครูฟ้ามีคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็
นั่ง
นานครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ใกล้หรือว่าอยู่ไกล
The  Face ร้านกาแฟแอยู่ใกล้หรือไกล
ม่านครูฟ้าเนี่ย
คิดอยู่นะว่ากินข้าวเฟไว้หรือว่าร้านกาแฟ
ใกล้ๆบ้านอยู่ไกลค่ะผู้หญิงอยู่ไกลหรอ
อยู่ไกลถ้าครูฟ้าอยากไปคาเฟ่อยากไปร้าน
กาแฟเดินไม่ได้ไม่ได้เหนื่อยมากเดินไม่
ได้รถในหรือขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์โอเค
ขอบคุณไม่กี่นาทีเหรอคะครูฟ้าฟ้ารู้ไหม
ประมาณ 15 นาทีมั้งอันนี้คือขับรถนะคะขับ
รถหรือว่าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
15 นาที
55 นาทีเนอะโอ้ไกลนะคะบ้านครูฟ้าแล้วก็
คาเฟ่ร้านกาแฟไกลนี้นะคะ
คอนโดครูหญิงราคาไกล Cafe ไหมหรือว่าใกล้
ว่าไอ้ค่ะครูฟ้า
ไม่คาเฟ่ผู้หญิงเดินโอเคยิงอะไรคะ
Condominium ครูหญิงนะมีทาเฟ Cafe คาเฟ่
ใกล้ๆเยอะ
เนี่ยมี 1  2  3  4 คู่หญิงแม่เดินใกล้
มากๆเดิน 1 นาทีเล่นเซเว่นคาเฟ่อันนี้
ใกล้มากๆน่ะแต่ถ้าเดินนิดหน่อยก็จะมี
คาเฟ่
โอเคสวยก็เดินประมาณ 10 นาทีมีคาเฟ่แบบ
นี้เลยค่ะสวยมาก
เงียบก้าแฟร์ดี
ก็ดีมากค่ะค่ะและสิ่งที่ฟ้าชอบไปเป็นฟี่
นะคะสายฟ้ามาบ้านผู้หญิงค่ะใกล้ๆ
คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงมี Cafe  Cafe  Cafe
Cafe  Cafe  Cafe  Cafe  Cafe มายนัก
เรียนเยอะมากเยอะมากใช่ค่ะครูฟ้ามีคาเฟ่
แบบเยอะมากๆนะเพราะว่าเป็นชิกเซอร์ Sister
area นะคะคาเฟ่เยอะคนก็เยอะนะคะๆต่อไป
ค่ะครูฟ้าในค่ะมีอะไรอีกในรูปเนี่ยที่ไหน
คะครูฟ้าในรูปเนี่ยทะเลค่ะทะเลครูฟ้า
เนี่ยที่บ้านอยู่พัทยาใช่ไหมบ้านครูฟ้า
เนี่ยอยู่ใกล้หรือว่าอยู่ไกลทะเลคะ
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยญี่ปุ่นยินดีค่ะโอ้
ทำไมนักเรียนมีคำถาม
อยู่ไกลนักเรียนพัทยามันใหญ่อ่ะอ๋อ
แล้วถ้าจากบ้านครูฟ้านี้บ้านครูไฟล์กูมา
อยู่ไกลใช่มั้ยนี้คือบ้านครูฟ้านะคะเล็กๆ
มาแล้วก็ไปไปๆบ้านครูฟ้าไปทะเล
เดินไม่ได้เนาะในได้
ขับรถกี่นาทีถึงทะเลขับรถประมาณ 20 นาที
ให้
ไกลนะที่ครูฟ้าไม่ขับรถไม่ขับรถเดิน
จากบ้านเดินทะเล
เดินสู่
3 ชั่วโมงมั้ง
ใจค่ะมีความสูงก็คู่ฟ้าเดินแล้วก็โอ้
อาหาร KFC กิน God
แตก
บ้านครูหญิงกับทะเล
ใกล้ไหมคะไม่ใกล้ค่ะไกลมาก
เดินได้มั้ย
เดินไม่ได้เออบ้านบ้านครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ไปไปไปไปไปทะเลที่ใกล้ที่สุด
ก็คือขับรถ 2 ชั่วโมง
ขับรถ 2 ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
บางแสนค่ะบางแสนพัทยาบ้านครูป๊าแม่จาก
บ้านครูหญิงนะคอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงแหละไป
ทะเลขับรถ 2 ชั่วโมงน้องผู้หญิงอยู่
กรุงเทพฯไหมครูถ้าไม่มีทะเลก็เลยไกลแต่
ไกลมากนะไตรมารคหน้าโหผู้หญิงก็มาทะเลแบบ
ไกลมากนะจ่ายค่ะอะอีกรูปนึงเนาะ
ถนนนะคะถนนน่ะบ้านครูฟ้าอันนี้บ้านครูฟ้า
นะคะบ้าน
ไปสิเอาไปอย่างนี้อะนี่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ใกล้ถนนหรือว่าอยู่ไกลถนนคะ
ลิ้งค์หน้าบ้านครูบาก็มีถนนนะ
งั้นบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่ติดถนนด้วยเพราะใกล้
มาก
เป็นถนนยังไงอ่ะ
[เพลง]
rang551
น้อยต้องมี 1 เลนส์ 2 เลนส์
ก็ใกล้ค่ะบ้างฟ้าใกล้หนุนเดินได้เดิน
ประมาณ 1 นาทีอันนี้ใกล้นะแค่บ้านครูฟ้า
ใกล้นะคะเพราะต้องเดินแล้วก็ถนนนายถนน
บ้านครูหญิงไม่ถนนไหมคะใกล้มากๆค่ะผู้
หญิงบอกว่าบ้านครูหญิงติดถนนก็คืออันนี้
คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงแล้วก็ข้างหน้าข้าง
หน้า Condominium ถนนนะคะคืออยู่ติดถนนก็
คือใกล้มากๆสวยถ้าบ้านครูฟ้าแล้วก็ตรงนี้
จะหน้าเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นนะคะก็คือบ้านครู
ฟ้าอยู่ใกล้เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นมากๆบ้านครู
ฟ้าอยู่ติดเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นไปบ้านครูหญิง
อยู่ติดถนนหน้าอยู่ติดถนนเลยเนาะ
สายค่ะก็เราก็มาถามครูฟ้าใช่ไหมว่าบ้าน
ครูฟ้าบ้านครูหญิงอยู่ใกล้อะไรอยู่ไกลที่
ไหนนะคะแล้วบ้านนักเรียนล่ะอยู่ใกล้กับ
ที่ไหน
คอมเม้นบอกได้นะคะนักเรียนว่าอยู่ใกล้
อยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้อยู่ใกล้นะเทศสิ่งหนึ่ง
รอบหรือว่าอยู่อะไรนะคะใกล้ๆไกลๆไกลๆไกลๆ
ๆนะคะโอเควันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ